hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on high throughput
native ms with robust ion source
operation for the analysis of proteins
and protein complexes by dr caroline chu
an ls i'm sorry an lcms application
scientist with agilent and i'm cece
valdez of labyrinths and i'll be your
moderator for today's event before we
begin i want to encourage you to engage
with us you can submit as many questions
as you want at any time you want during
the presentation just simply type them
into the ask a question box to the left
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation just click on that support
tab found at the top right
and use the ask question box on the left
please join me now in welcoming dr chu
you may now begin your presentation
hi thanks for joining me today as we
talk about a little bit on high
throughput native ms
with robust ion source operation for the
analysis of proteins and protein
complexes
um
as a refresher just for those that are
not familiar with native mass spec
native mass spec is a little bit
different from denaturing mass spec
in native mass spec the protein retains
its native form in its folded form under
biological conditions at ph 7
usually with the ammonium acetate as our
buffer ranging from
50 millimolar to 200 millimolar
concentration um
it is a charge limiting application so a
little bit more challenging to ionize
um
you can do it
uh two ways essentially online
um size exclusion chromatography for
online desulting and offline buffer
exchange and then introducing it into
the mass spec with um
usually nano
so denaturing conditions is more
commonly used it's a low ph
and an organic buffer is usually used
which causes the protein to unfold and
you get a very nice charge envelope it
is definitely not charge limiting and
it's usually done by reverse phase and
can be used by any one of our um
ionization sources such as the ajs
esi and
nano esi
so in my previous webinars we talked
about um
uh comprehensive approaches to doing
native mass spec here we're just looking
at the liquid chromatography
introduction
of um
these proteins under biological ph seven
so here we're using a 1290 infinity 2 lc
um
uh plc
and you can do it um one of three ways
actually
um the traditional way is by doing it
with nano esi so here on the top you can
see
the nano adapter so that
converts the
high flow to nano flow
and you can interchange it with the g
1992 a nano space nano spray interface
or alternatively we've done a lot of cap
flow work with our standard esi source
you can do it under cap or micro flow
rates and what we'll talk about today is
um something we've recently introduced
this year earlier this year which is the
agilent gesturing source under standard
flow conditions
so
any one of those conditions i outlined
in the previous
slide with the nano esi or ajs source
can be coupled to any one of our high
resolution accurate mass um qtof systems
so
what i'm showing you here are some of
the commonly used platforms
or um this analysis so here you have the
6230 top from the left
a 6530 qtof 6545xt
which will be the primary focus of our
talk today
as well as the 6560 im mobility um
qtof so as you can see
there's different options you can use
for the high resolution accurate mass
system
you can still do it with our base model
toff or the base model cutoff
for larger complexes you'll see the 6545
xt offers you an extended mass range and
for those higher order structure
analysis where you get that added
dimension of
ion mobility separation for
conformational studies that's where the
6560 would be um a great instrument to
utilize
so
how did this high flow work come about
so this is work done with my colleague
um pat perkins
and
gotten he basically got inspired by
doing
a rapid online buffer exchange
system so we initially had a lot of
capillary flow work
um and then now we've moved on to high
flow work
based on this publication by uh vikki
wysocki's group
and so we decided to take utilize that
kind of
publication as a platform
and migrating it over using our agilent
jet stream
technology
with our mass specs
so here you can see the publication on
the left and
an application note that kind of covers
uh what the adjunct just stream
is about
so from that we basically were it was
able to
generate a poster for asms um 2020 this
year it's uh
mp499 and so what we'll do in this talk
is kind of walk through this poster go
into a little bit more details about how
we use standard flow native ms for these
protein complexes
so these are the analytical conditions
that we use for the astronaut gesturing
source for those who are not familiar
with the agilent version source this is
basically what it looks like so on our
mass specs all our sources are
interchangeable with each other so
whether you have a tough q top or a
triple quad those sources are all
interchangeable between each of those
platforms
and so here we utilize um
the agilent advanced bio scc cartridge
uh guard column
and we basically leave it at room
temperature
and our injection volumes vary we have a
20 microliter loop on our 12 1952 system
um so we can inject upwards of 20
microliters depending on the
concentration of your sample mobile
phases range from 100 to 200 millimolar
ammonium acetate and the flow rate is a
lot higher than what we normally would
use which is a 0.5 0.4 mils per minute
and it's an isocratic run and
essentially it's a six minute run
below are the source conditions outlined
for the ajs source
and what i've gone ahead and done is
kind of give you a brief brief
introduction to what the agilent gesture
source is so you can find more
information on the application note that
i had just shown previously and so
basically at the actual gesture source
it
basically kind of gives you a way of
culminating the spray so here is what it
would look like without the super heated
sheath gas that is introduced so you can
have you see here your sample is in
green
the solvent is in the blue droplets the
drying gas here is in the black um
black
iron
and then the orange would be the agilent
gesturing gas which is introduced with
the ajs source so here it is without the
aging gestures gas so you can see where
the spray is more
wider and you can see you know more of
your
sample along with the solvent does get
entered into the
mass spec itself so you have an increase
in noise
and in here you can see this is a
picture from the
uh jet agilent jet stream application
note where you can see the spray
um starting at 25 degrees c
so when you enable the sh the super
heated sheath gas with the agilent jet
stream source you can now see the sheath
gas being introduced here which now kind
of focuses in the spray
a lot better
where the neutrals are then
moved out
down into the waist
and it focuses in the samples into the
mass spec itself and eliminating a lot
of neutrals from going into the mass
spec
so now you've essentially improved a lot
of your
signal versus the noise that's entering
the mass spec
and then here is just um
an illustration of what the aging
stretch mean source looks like at
350 degrees c so with the superheated
sheath gas so now you can see the spray
is a lot more focused
in
for the analytical setup is basically
you just put in um
the
advanced file sec guard column here you
can see that here
and we can use it um with a 10 port
valve
plumb to emulate a six port valve or you
can just have a six port valve and
essentially you know you can use um
the valve changing
procedure so that you can do some
offline cleanup and desalting
to give you an idea of what the
chromatogram looks like here is a
picture of the total iron chromatogram
using alcohol dehydrogenase
adh so alcohol dehydrogenase is like a
146 kilodalton tetramer homo tetramer
and so that was our base standard for
doing a lot of the method optimization
and development for this whole procedure
here
and so here on the left you can see the
tic of the alcohol dehydrogenase
tetramer
and you can see where the highlighted
region is where the adh does elude off
the column
and then followed by this larger
peak
which is mainly a small
molecular weight singly charged species
and to give you an idea what the mass
spectral looks like
you can see on the right is the mass
spectrum of adh and you can see the
charge envelope it's far more extended
into the five to six thousand mr z range
and it does extend out further
with the ajs source
so for the source optimization not only
do we take into account the temperature
of the gas the drying gas temperature we
also took into account the sheath gas
temperature the different flow rates as
well as the nebulizer pressure
and so for both of these you know if
you're familiar with some of our
previous work on native ms we did a lot
of work with the cap flow with the
microflow nebulizer so here we're using
the standard flow nebulizer with the ajs
source but it is still possible to use
the microflow nebulizer with the ajs
source and you'll see an improvement in
your sensitivity
and so what you'll see here is just
monitoring a single charge state um mm6
6147
the area of that um that charge state
versus the sheath gas so changing in the
sheath gas and then the changing in the
area of that single charge state so you
can see the plot here on the left which
is the 24 plus charge state
and then if you were to um
to also monitor the response of
a couple different charge states kind of
like the apex of the charge envelope
with the nebulizer pressure you can also
see the response of
you know the shifting of the charge
envelope along with the nebulizer
pressure here
so once all the initial experiments were
done with the
source optimization with
alcohol dehydrogenase uh a number of
standards were explored under these
analytical conditions to ensure that you
know we we have the right conditions for
these non-covalent complexes
so um more commonly commonly used you
know we're using monoclonal antibodies
on the 6545 xt
and so we use the nismab as well as um
perceptin
and we tried those two compounds out and
so here you can see on the left is
percepting 3.15 micrograms on column and
so what you'll see is the charge
envelope as well as in the inlet here a
zoom in at the apex of the different um
charge states
and so you can still see the glycoforms
retained under these um
uh
analytical conditions with the native ms
on the right is a mismatch with
comparable um
concentration of three micrograms on
column the charge envelope and the zoom
in of the apex of the charge envelope so
you can see the
the relative intensities and the
distribution of the charge envelope
between the two monoclonal antibodies
are very much similar
and so what we what we did was went
ahead and used unideck
which is a
free software platform by dr michael
marty
and it is a great platform for using for
native ms
because it does help with the
deconvolution and it does have some
great features where it does also
annotate a lot of the um the charge
envelope so it's actually very
informative and a great way of
generating data and so we've been using
a lot of um dr marty's unidec for
um a lot of our non-covalent complexes
whether it's nano
esi tap
even um
the standard flow work and so what
you'll be seeing subsequently in the in
the next couple slides with the
standards uh are the analysis using
unideck for the native ms work
and so what you'll see here on the left
it are the charge envelopes
and then what you'll see is an overlay
of the the raw data which is in black
overlaid to the fit data where there is
some peak fitting as well as some
smoothing um occurring
um
over the charge envelope itself so this
is what it would look like after the fit
data overlay to the raw
and then to the right are the annotated
peaks with the charge states
and you can see that the distribution
across the charge states and then once
deconvoluted you can see the
deconvoluted masses and then we went
ahead and zoomed in so you can see the
glyco forms
and so we went ahead and tried a number
of other complexes so
for
adh you know as our standard we went
ahead and used them smaller proteins
just to see because you know mass native
effect can be utilized for you know a
number of different proteins and they
vary in size so we wanted to kind of go
across the mass range a little bit to
give you kind of an idea of how the
standard flow work
may may be helpful for doing a lot of
the native work in your laboratory
so here we see the the raw data this is
um
off the xt without any special
smoothing or peak fitting and you'll see
from the left here is bovine serum
albumin which is a monomer
at 66 kilodaltons enolase
93.6 kilodaltons and it's a dimer and
then our standard for this um for this
work alcohol dehydrogenase at 148
kilograms it's a homo tetramer
so first we have the bovine serum
albumin
you can see uh this is 20 picomoles on
column and with the unidecte convolution
on the upper left are is the fitted data
which is the smoothing and baseline and
peak um peak fitting over the raw data
to the right are the annotated charge
states
um for this particular protein and then
what's really great is that there's also
a heat map where it's um the plot of the
charge versus the m over z
and
it may be a little bit more challenging
to see here but you can see that the
monomer you can see the monomer
trend line as well as that there's a
dimer formation there which then
coincides with what we see with the
deconvoluted results where we see the
monomer at 66 kilozone then we also see
a dimer
a little bit further up so it did
dimerize in the mass back
next we see enolase which is a
dimer itself so again the fit data
is on the left upper left and then you
can see on the upper right are the
charge on
the charge envelope with the on
annotations and what's really nice here
is that you can actually see which peaks
correspond to the monomer and which
peaks correspond to the dimer and so the
monomer you can see the the peak
annotations in these purple dots
and then what you'll see for the dimer
are these uh red inverted triangles
and then in the heat map you can now see
that the two different trend lines for
the monomer and the dimer
and then so once the completed you can
associate the two so we do see that for
some compounds
this higher flow may need some more
additional work to keep it in a dimer
form as well as um
some may just have in weaker
interactions that may not be amenable to
high flow rates at the higher flow rates
which doesn't mean that it's not
possible to do we do have alternative
options
so here we look at alcohol dehydrogenase
deconvoluted again the fit data on the
upper left charge envelope on the right
and now you can see the beautiful trend
line for the charge envelope and the
deconvoluted mass
so we decided to take it one step
further and try
to go to the higher masses so we we went
ahead and explored pyruvate kinase which
is a 237 kilodalton uh homo tetramer
and then glutamate dehydrogenase at 318
kilodons which is a hexamer
nm beta galactosidase uh at 465 kilotons
and that's another touch trimmer so you
can see it is spanning across the mass
range which is one of the benefits of
the 6545 xt but it is one of the systems
that does go to the extended mass range
of thirty thousand ammo version
so here we look at um
pyruvate kinase
you can see the fit data overlaid onto
the raw data itself and in the
annotations
of the charge envelopes and you'll see
uh different types of annotations there
which corresponds to different geeks
and then you can see now the the heat
map and then you can see the
deconvoluted mass for
pyruvate kinase again at 20 pico moles
on column
next we look at glutamate dehydro
dehydrogenase
318 kilojones the hexamer and again you
can see the fit data overlay to the raw
data on the upper left and then the
charge envelope distributions with
annotation you can see now how it's all
plotted nicely down here in the charge
versus the m over z
and you see it deconvolutes
well into the 300 kilo down range
lastly we look at um beta galactosidase
and we're looking at a 465 kilodalton
tetramer again 20 picomoles on column
and you can now see the charge envelope
with the fit data overlay to the raw
data and then the charge envelope with
the charge state annotations
and then you can also see the beautiful
heat map here with the charge versus m
over z
and a deconvoluted mass itself here
and so
you know this is this is work that we
have put together this year and so we've
now gone ahead and extended it and
applied it to different um applications
here for example is a recently published
uh
poster that our intern kate zimmermaker
uh presented at a recent conference last
week
and we're using this exact analytical
condition the standard flow native mass
spec to characterize non-covalent
complexes of bsa with
hydroxism cinnamic acids by native ms so
she's exploring different library of
small molecules and looking at
different interactions between the
bsa and these um small molecules
and as i mentioned before you know
some as you've seen some of the examples
it may not all be amenable to the
standard flow conditions
um
it would really depend on the user and
we would definitely want to work with
you on getting the right conditions
um so
you know you will see some cases where
these complexes or interactions may not
be amenable to these standard flow rates
it doesn't mean it's impossible on our
systems so what i'm saying is that you
can still explore other options and so
i'm bringing back to this slide here
we can still use electrospray esi
microflow rates and so we're looking at
instead of a six minute run you may be
looking at a 13 to 15 minute run
depending on how you want to
adjust the flow rate so it's still a
very robust
and high throughput approach to um
doing this analysis um
compared to the standard nano spray um
uh
approach however the nanospray is a
little bit more amenable to those where
you are sample limited so you would
actually need to do the offline buffer
exchange and run it by nano
and so with that i wanted to also
introduce to you the capital rates as i
mentioned earlier so
you're not limited to the standard flow
so here we've used the poly hydroxy
ethyl a column
it's a 1 by 50 millimeter column so it's
a little bit longer than what the
standard flow column would would be
and you're running essentially pretty
much
the same kind of buffer analytical
conditions
but
your your runtimes will be slightly
different depending on your flow rate so
here we're running at cap flow rate
about five microliters a minute and you
know you're looking at about a little
bit longer time of 30 30 um 30 minutes
however if you're going at 15 to 30
microliters a minute
you're looking at like 15
about 15 minutes for your run time so
again it's
you there is an approach whether it's
standard flow or microflow or nano esi
to do these
analytical
approaches for native ms
so with that i'd like to go ahead and
summarize what we went ahead and talked
about briefly today
i went ahead and introduced you to our
standard flow approach with online
size exclusion chromatography with the
agilent gesture source
which is about six minutes long
and
it the
the data can be readily analyzed using
unideck or with our bioconfirm software
um
non-covalent complexes can be readily um
identified um using the advanced bio lc
cutoff so what i'm showing you here on
the left is grow el which is what we've
done
in the past using nano esi
it's an 801 kilodalton
protein
and what you'll see is the in
the analysis done by unideck and you can
see the beautiful charge envelope with
the charge the annotations
the charge versus mr z plot as well as
the convoluted mass so again this method
is not just limited to the xt
you can use this method on the 6200 tops
um you can use it on the 6500 series
qtofs um the xt is more highlighted
because it does have the extended mass
range and um the vacuum that which is
more amenable to
lower concentrations
and before i conclude i want to
acknowledge
that this work was done in collaboration
with my colleagues at agilent especially
pat perkins who has now retired
and so this was
a great
honor of mine to be able to present with
him this year
some of the neat work that we're able to
do with native mass spec
and with that i'll go ahead and conclude
thank you dr chu for that informative
presentation we will now move to the
live q and a portion of our presentation
just ask a question using the ask a
question box on the left and click send
dr 2 it looks like we already have some
great questions coming in
our first question
is how easy would it be to switch from
standard flow to capillary flow native
ms
so that's actually a pretty
straightforward um approach to this
because
um
your your system if you recently
purchased your mass spec within the last
couple years it already comes with an
ajs source and if you're familiar with
the agilent platforms our sources are
interchangeable
so you can easily use the ajs source
and try the microflow nebulizer and drop
the temperatures down
and switch it to you know microflow or
cap flow or alternatively what i had
presented was using the esi source so
you can just switch that over put the
microflow nebulizer and then you
use a
1 by 50 millimeter column to do your
online sec for native
thank you so much dr tube and do you
perform any sort of baseline subtraction
on your data before deconvolution
so that's a really great question um so
using the unidex software it does offer
you the ability to do some baseline
subtraction i avoid it if i don't have
to do the baseline subtraction but for
some of the proteins you'll see kind of
the baseline kind of rise towards the um
the higher m over z so that's where the
baseline subtraction along with the peak
picking um for the the uh
predicting the peak shape does come
in handy for the deconvolution
thank you very much and i want to thank
our audience for these great questions
coming in
our next question
from our present from our audience is
i have a question the native ms um
spectra the z envelope of the
perceptin the nist and some of the other
proteins did not look like a normal
distribution in your slides 12 and 13
which seemed to be a bit different from
the native specter i've seen in my own
data and other published data do you
have any thoughts about that
that is a great question we also noticed
the same thing when we first initially
ran these experiments and so you know
we've we've have a good repository of
what
the distribution looks like for native
ms because we do have it by capillary
flow um microflow nano flow
and we've done some ce experiments on it
so what we do suspect is that there is
um some possible charge stripping that's
occurring which then causes your mrz
mass shift to be on the higher m over z
which doesn't have as much of a gaussian
distribution but it tends to kind of
tail into the higher m over z so we're
currently exploring you know um
different um ways to kind of see if that
is the the the answer but we are
suspecting there is some level of charge
stripping that might that might be
occurring
thank you so much
our next question in which format do the
data have to be saved to use in unidesk
and um
the
audience member also wants you to know
that it's justin from lavell university
in quebec and great presentation she
wants you to know
thanks susie hi justin tay good to see
you
um the data format that you can use is
very straightforward so basically you go
into your qual or your bio confirm
and you pick out the spectrum that
you're looking to do and you go ahead
and export it as a csv
format
and um the easiest way is just kind of
deleting the first row in the first
column so you essentially just have your
your data point and then the um so
essentially m over z and then your
abundance so those two columns and it um
readily can be opened up in unideck
however i do know that unideck is
supporting the agile files
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience this is great q a
do you think that the source ionization
parameters would differ for different
proteins and have to be an optimized for
every experiment dr chu
in a sense
yes
what we're giving to you is a kind of a
general starting parameter right and so
oftentimes it may need to be fine-tuned
if you look at some of the proteins that
we explored we explored a a
subset of standards to kind of gauge how
the protein response would be
while these are non-covalent complexes
some do fall apart under the standard
flow approach while some do retain their
um
their native form so again there is
going to be some level of optimis
optimization that you would need
but at this point what we present to you
not only with the standard flow but all
our other analytical conditions for
native ms is a good starting point for
you to kind of just tweak so that way
you don't have to start from scratch
and it it it's
at least gets you a jump start you know
we're currently exploring you know um as
you can see with a recent post that we
presented exploring it with the uh
ligand com complexes so we're seeing how
we would need to adjust from there as
well so
that's a great question but yeah there's
gonna be some level of adjustment needed
thank you so much and we have time for a
couple more questions
our next audience member asks i've never
worked with proteins before can i do it
in the native ms
absolutely so basically you know we've
given you the analytical conditions the
hardware setup and how to kind of set
everything up um
but what i would say is that if you
don't need to do native and you can get
away with denaturing mass spec and still
get your intact mass measurements then
we have uh
already pretty much standardized methods
for doing that you know when you
purchase the xd it comes with the method
for denaturing ms along with the column
native ms is more so for those that are
looking for non-covalent complexes
binding studies um that type of
workflows but if you're just looking for
intact protein
you can still just do need a denaturing
mass spec
thank you so much we have time for one
more question dr chu
does agilent have nano flow systems
coupled to the ms spectrum spectrometer
yes so if you saw um a slide that i
presented at the beginning as well as at
the end of the presentation just to kind
of refresh everyone's memory is that um
we do offer what we call the
nano adapter so what that is is that
basically takes your 1290 high flow uh
plc
system and it basically turns it into a
nano flow delivery system
so it kind of essentially splits your
flow so that you do have nano flow and
you couple it with our g1992a
nano esi interface on any one of our you
know qtos then you can have your nano uh
flow set up so you really don't have to
kind of get a full on you know nano flow
lc system but you can just use your
existing uh plc and convert that over
thank you so much dr chu and before i
offer you an opportunity to provide some
closing remarks i want to welcome john
sawson from agilent to add a few extra
comments to our audience john are you
there
i am thank you very much carolyn great
talk thanks
um i just wanted to offer that quick
other comment on the low flow nano flow
capability um and uh uh carolyn
commented very well on the comment of
using the nano adapter but tomorrow
afternoon we're actually going to have a
presentation from lin fang
wu on the uh evosep
low flow lc and so
um we've signed a co-marketing agreement
with evosep with the intent that we can
now also offer uh you know it's hard to
put the words robust and nano all in the
same sentence but evosep has done a
really nice job of improving robustness
on low flow with their cartridge based
systems and method transfer so you'll
get a chance tomorrow afternoon to see
lin peng's presentation using the uh
evocep low flow she's running 0.1
millimeter id columns for that
thanks
thank you so much john and thank you
again and i want to thank our audience
dr two would you like to provide our
audience with some closing remarks
before we go
um sure so
what i presented today was kind of like
a brief introduction to doing standard
flow native ms and it was done showing
you the data off the 6545xt but i just
want to reiterate that if you have an
existing you know top 6200 top um 6500
qtox 6520 6530
you know um or even imobility you can
readily do native ms
thank you so much dr chu for your time
today and for your important research
and as a reminder to our audience
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during on-demand
period will be addressed via the email
you provided during your time of
registration
and i want to thank you again dr chu and
everyone who participated today we hope
you will check out the exhibit hall and
enjoy the rest of the agilent event
today and tomorrow take care stay
healthy bye bye for now